your doctor may recommend you receive a
blood transfusion to treat your medical
condition or to save your life your
blood carries oxygen and nutrients to
all of your tissues and removes carbon
dioxide and other waste products from
them blood also helps fight infection
and heal wounds blood consists of a
liquid portion and cellular components
the liquid called plasma is where
nutrients hormones clotting factors and
other chemicals are dissolved the
cellular components are suspended in the
plasma
they consist of red blood cells which
transport oxygen and carbon dioxide
white blood cells which fight infection
and platelets which are small sub cells
that help the blood to clot
blood cells are made in the bone marrow
a soft tissue housed inside many of your
bones a blood transfusion uses donor
blood to replenish red blood cells white
blood cells platelets clotting factors
plasma or whole blood circumstances that
may require a blood transfusion include
blood loss due to trauma heart or other
major surgery organ transplants bleeding
disorders such as hemophilia severe
anemia including sickle cell anemia
treatment for leukemia or other types of
cancer disorders that destroy blood
cells or bone marrow or Rh
incompatibility in newborn babies to
begin the transfusion and intravenous
needle will be inserted into a vein in
your hand or arm a bag containing the
donor blood will be hung nearby and the
blood will drip slowly through a tube
attached to the IV needle allowing it to
run through your vein into your
bloodstream throughout the transfusion
your temperature heart rate breathing
and blood pressure will be monitored
after the bag is empty if you require
more blood another bag will be attached
to the IV tube when your transfusion is
completed the needle will be removed
after your transfusion your doctor will
monitor your vital signs to make sure
you are not having an adverse reaction
if necessary you may be given a diuretic
to reduce any swelling or fluid
retention